[Music]
the pandemic has turned
rita campo's life upside down
the fear of getting infected and losing
her job have led to depression
i was caught off guard by sadness and
overwhelming tiredness
it was the result of having to work at
home while taking care of my son
i have to make lunch and dinner every
day and help him learn while also
helping my family
my number of household tasks was
multiplied by ten
multiplicos some anti-anxiety medication
is out of stock in portugal
antidepressants are up by as much as 11
percent
there's a rise in alcohol and drug abuse
domestic violence
panic attacks and suicide
the covert 19 pandemic has caused
a mental health crisis in our region
at a scale that we've never seen before
some doctors believe lockdowns and
self-isolation
are more damaging to society than the
virus itself
depression is taboo in some countries
that makes today's topic
tricky for nigerians it's estimated one
in four people struggle with mental
illness in africa's most populous nation
but there's little help here's funifacha
this is a hard place to catch a break
millions of people here are struggling
just to get
by and there are concerns the pandemic
could push even more people into poverty
and depression 250
that's the number of psychiatrists
available in nigeria
250 in a country of 200 million people
where so many struggle with some sort of
mental illness
but only very few have access to the
help they need
you don't have to look far to find
people struggling
many are trying to protect their
livelihoods and their mental health
so how much is a crayfish
two five that's the last it can be two
five madam is
one thousand two i'm not the price
amara is self-employed her job buying up
beans or crayfish at a good price for
resale
but with the pandemic most of her
clients restaurants
have shut down when i got news
from my customers that they're no more
interested
at first it was like are they serious
so i didn't take that as i kept pushing
i sent them messages i called at the
time one of them responded that
amara let's see how it goes after covid
how am i supposed to know when could be
to be over
the uncertainty was too much she says
it started to weigh her down back in
april
she began to experience symptoms of
depression
at times i'll get up at night i'll just
be sleeping at night
i'll just be thinking i was thinking of
a whole lot
how do i manage this how do i take care
of a lot of things
surrounding me how do i take care of my
responsibility
and all that amara is one of millions
suffering from panic attacks and anxiety
but there is a stigma associated with
any form of mental illness
in nigeria once you come out to talk
about it you'll be termed
this lady has gone nuts a lot of people
see it as
a big deal or a big scene
professional help is expensive so far
amara has only been able to afford
one therapy session for 50 us dollars
not enough to heal olayinka is one of
the few psychiatrists remaining in
nigeria
most of her colleagues have left seeking
better payment
abroad she decided to stay
if we don't take mental health seriously
the population won't be as productive as
we
would expect and of course eventually
the company the country will lose
economically we should put mental health
on the
on the front she wants the government to
subsidize
treatment if we don't prioritize mental
health
right now we could have more cases of
suicide more
more more issues more domestic violence
more
infanticides more issues going on
because people won't seek for help but
they would take out
take it out on someone else with many
nigerians
only beginning to feel the economic and
mental impact of the covet pandemic
the situation remains highly volatile
mental health is a talking point in
germany a well-off country with a solid
welfare system
still calls to corona crisis hotlines
have spiked just as in many other
countries
in some places the surging demand for
antidepressants has led to shortages
the great lockdown had already hit
manufacturers supply chains
and the number of americans who googled
information about
panic and anxiety attacks reached a
16-year high
as the novel coronavirus initially
spread across the u.s
well experts say you're not alone you've
no doubt seen the slogan
leave no one behind a sense of community
is a real positive that's emerged from
this crisis
where social creatures living in
self-isolation just
isn't easy kyoda has more
in 2003 a previously unknown virus
caused the severe acute respiratory
syndrome known as sars
more than 8 000 people were infected and
thousands were quarantined
[Music]
rima styra conducted research into the
mental health of people
during their sars quarantine
and what we found was that there was a
high percentage of people who had
both ptsd and depression
from having been in quarantine during
the sars episode
so what we found when we talk about ptsd
what we know is that people feel upset
hopeless depressed angry
frustrated they feel there's a lack of
control
how can you basically explain the fact
that people get this
ptsd or experienced depression
so so i think what happens is you know
post-traumatic stress symptoms okay
so that's what they're starting to
experience is the fact that it's a
traumatic event
and for people when they were sort of
thinking about the fact that they might
develop
stars or in this particular case
coronavirus
you're thinking about am i going to make
it when am i going to feel the symptoms
oh i have a bit of a cough oh you know
i have a little bit harder to breathe is
is this coming on
although the current coronavirus
pandemic is also throwing up such fears
there are differences now too and some
of these could even have a positive
effect
on people's mental health
now there's more of a sense of community
so what we see now
is there's so many people in isolation
that people don't feel they're the only
ones
you know there's a lot more
communication as well now
we have technologies the other thing
that's happened this time which is very
different from
sars is that there's a lot of
psychological support
what are the things that people can do
if they find themselves now in
isolation keep in touch with family and
friends by using technology
they will provide you a tremendous
amount of support the other thing
is setting out a routine and routine
helps in calming
one's fears and anxieties
even though the world might seem grim at
the moment we should remember that there
are still things we can do for ourselves
and for others not everything is beyond
our control
time to hand you over to our science
correspondent derek williams he's been
looking into the questions you've been
sending us on youtube
does plasma therapy work and if so
when should it be administered
this is another of those questions that
needs regular updates since
our knowledge in the area continues
to evolve um just a reminder a
convalescent plasma
is isolated from the blood of patients
who've recovered from the disease
and and it contains antibodies that help
keep someone who's had it once
um from catching it again antibody rich
plasma can also be given to others as
a medication um the method has been used
to treat
patients in in a range of epidemics for
for over
a century now but it's proven
surprisingly
difficult to determine just how
effective
it is as a therapy for people who have
contracted
covet 19. there's a couple of different
reasons
why not least uh that it's hard to carry
out
double-blind studies involving placebos
with with people who are in the middle
of trying to fight off
a potentially lethal disease although
plasma therapy has been given to many
covet patients
in dire circumstances when doctors have
run out of options
there's still no really convincing
randomized control trials showing that
the convalescent plasma
really does help um despite that earlier
this week
the food and drug administration in the
u.s gave it what's called
an emergency use authorization which is
quite a controversial move since since a
lot of scientists believe
we just don't have enough evidence yet
to justify it
and they say that political factors must
be playing a role
in the decision there is some
preliminary
evidence that that convalescent plasma
therapy
might be helping some people who receive
high doses of it quite early after
diagnosis
but but there's still a lot of work left
to be done
before we reach what we would call
substantial proof
[Music]
most of us are getting used to all the
new hygiene rules like masks
but for those requiring a little extra
protection
how about this space helmet it's
designed by colombian startup
ql concepts and while the helmet may
look a little out of this world
it has an important purpose protecting
frontline workers like nurses and
doctors
the company sold 120 of the 3d printed
headgear to customers in colombia el
salvador
and the united states
and if you still haven't mastered the
art of mask
wearing check out how good the japanese
are with these handheld masks
diners in kyoto have been giving them a
test run holding the masks in their free
hand to
cover their mouths when not taking a
bite the idea comes from kyoto saga
university of arts
the prototypes are made of paper or
non-woven fabric with handles attached
students will use the test run to
further refine the masks
you